man's doing the right thing in the right
amounts and and by the way if we're
talking about the ways in which I think
men and women should be
um what's the word in their natural sort
of Aura let's say it's it's um it's
exactly that men should be the the
leader okay that's that's fine but I
don't think men are leaders these days
so the problem is is that they expect
well because women emasculate them
constantly or maybe they allow
themselves to be emasculated I mean it's
it's tough when every every sitcom
you've seen since you were a child
emasculates the father I mean look at
look at take the Simpsons what's it's a
dumb dad the smart bomb like men are
told they ain't [__] from a young age
like why why is it okay to say men are
trash men are trash but it's not okay to
say women are [__]
no they're trash too
um yeah